-You guys, we have been so happy
to have Fred Armisen
with us all week.
Fred, how are you, my friend?
-I'm doing great.
-It's so exciting
to have you here for a week
and this is really
exciting, too --
it is Opening Day
in Major League Baseball.
I know you're a huge sports fan,
a huge baseball fan, huge.
-Huge, huge. Baseball.
[ Laughter ]
-Which team do you think
has the best chances?
-Phillies.
-Great.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Phillies all the way.
-Phillies everywhere.
But I also heard --
is this true --
that you are launching,
next week is the opening day
of your rival baseball league?
-Yes.
-That's so exciting.
[ Laughter ]
-So I have this baseball league
that is like
it's players from every team...
-Uh-huh.
-...in both leagues,
National and American.
-Great.
You do know a lot
about baseball.
-I do.
[ Laughter ]
But it's less about like,
"I'm from this team
or that team."
It's more like a crowd
of players on the field.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Right?
And it's more like
let's have fun.
Let's throw a bunch
of baseballs around.
[ Laughter ]
Like it doesn't have to be
so many rules.
That's like from another time.
Let's all just enjoy
this moment.
-Okay.
-So --
-So it's just a bunch of guys
on the field,
throwing balls around?
-Yeah, but in a way
that's like sort of, you know,
with enjoyment.
-Do --
[ Laughter ]
Is there a way to keep score?
-Yeah. So, so,
for every three times
that someone catches a ball,
right,
that's 7 points.
[ Laughter ]
Every fourth time, zero points.
Any fastball that goes
to left field,
where four people catch those,
10 points, with 5 subtracted,
if it's from the opposing team.
[ Laughter ]
-And that's it.
-Those are the only rules?
-Those are the only rules.
-Wait, how long
does the game take?
-Five minutes.
-Okay.
-Quickly, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And what is it called,
if we're looking for it?
-It's just called
regular baseball.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, great.
-Yeah.
-Give it up one more time
for Fred Armisen, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you.